[Music]
for much of the 19th century Spike
island is one of the most infamous
prisons on Earth it is synonymous with
death and suffering
by the New Evidence archaeologist Kirk
French is traveling to the star-shaped
prison on the Irish Coast hunting for
Bastion III
much of Spike Island Now lies in Ruins
but at its peak this prison was 10 times
the size of Alcatraz
Banks surrounding the jail were built by
the inmates themselves over 150 years
ago
but it's a hidden cell block that Drew
French here and to find it he's meeting
archaeologist Barra odunaworn an expert
on Spike Island
odunaworn leads French to the entrance
of a series of underground tunnels
it's quite a massive door